[Music]
like the masses
i wasn't all when i first laid eyes on
all the things you all
[Music]
i heard that speech i knew we'd make
noise
i just thought it'd be in the streets
the black panthers are the single
greatest threat to our national security
our counterintelligence program must
prevent the rise of a black messiah
you're looking at 18 months for the
stolen car
five years for impersonating a federal
officer
or you can go home what do you want
get close to hampton the black panthers
are forming a rainbow coalition of
oppressed brothers and sisters of every
color
neutralize him by any means necessary
[Music]
america's on fire right
and now that fire's extinguished
nothing else mean a damn thing imagine
what we could accomplish together
[Music]
we can heal this whole city you ain't
telling me it was gonna be like this
these ain't no terrorists we got a rat
man
does anybody else know about me no one
knows your identity are you sure
we educate we nurture we feel
and we lobby perhaps we're here for more
than just war
with these bodies he screamed
and he shouted and we lived by this
anthem
but his power to the people really
when i dedicated my life to people i
dedicated my life
you get to go out there and talk about
dying of revolutionary death
because you don't have another person
growing inside your body
anyway there's people it's power
[Music]
[Music]
you